[Musique]
il françois blanchet est né en 1965 à
drummondville en pleine révolution
tranquille dès 14 ans il obtient sa
carte du parti québécois à compter de
1990 yves françois blanchet bâti sa
carrière dans l'industrie musicale
il fonde une entreprise de production de
disque et du spectacle
il gère la carrière du chanteur éric
lapointe et dirigera l'adisq pendant
cinq ans en 2008 il sauve dans l'arène
politique avec le parti québécois il est
élu député de drôme année sera ministre
de l'environnement sous pauline marois
québec tonnes alors le dos au nucléaire
et à l'amiante et ouvre la porte au
pétrole de l'île d'anticosti
après sa défaite il françois blanchet
devient commentateur à l'émission les ex
à rdi le bloc québécois le convaincra de
revenir en politique en 2018